>> Greg: YOU REMEMBER EMINEM.
HERE'S A PICTURE IN CASE YOU
FORGOT.
STILL MAD AT DONALD TRUMP
BECAUSE HE WON'T RESPOND TO HIS
SAD WRAPS FELT THE PRESIDENT.
>> THAT'S AN AWFULLY HOT COFFEE
DONALD TRUMP QUESTION ARE
PROBABLY NOT BUT THAT'S ALL I
GOT.
>> Greg: GRAMPS IS SO
ADORABLE.
HE JUST TOLD A MUSIC JOURNALIST
THAT A BLANKING TURD WOULD BE A
BETTER PRESIDENT THAN
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
HE SAYS THIS TO MUSIC JOURNALIST
LIKE TRUMP HAS NO BUSINESS
TELLING THE NONRICH ANYTHING YET
EMINEM IS ALSO FILTHY RICH.
USING HIS LOGIC, WHY SHOULD
IT WOULD BE REFRESHING FOR HIM
TO HAVE A CONVERSATION WITH THE
PEOPLE HE DENIGRATES.
OFF AS AN IRRELEVANT CRANK.
BUT NOW JAY Z HAS KNOCKED TRUMP
AND TRUMP RESPONDED BACK.
THAT'S GOT TO KILL EMINEM.
APPARENTLY JAY Z WAS ASKED ABOUT
THE LOW BLACK UNEMPLOYMENT RATE
UNDER TRUMP.
JAY Z RESPONDED THAT'S NOT ABOUT
MONEY AT THE END OF THE DAY.
STUPID RICH.
ONE SAYS $1,000 AS A CRUMB.
ANOTHER SAYS A JOB ISN'T
BECAUSE THEY DON'T NEED EITHER.
EXCEPT FOR DRAMA.
HE NEVER SAYS THAT.
MAYBE THAT'S WHY HE'S PRESIDENT.
AND THEY AREN'T.
KENNEDY.
YOU ARE AN ALUM OF MTV.
VAN JONES SAID JAY Z IS A GOOD
ROLE MODEL FOR DONALD TRUMP
BECAUSE HE GREW IN PUBLIC.
HE WAS CONFESSIONAL AND
VULNERABLE ABOUT HIS MARRIAGE.
I DON'T THINK HE HAD A CHOICE IN
THAT.
>> Kennedy: NO.
BEYONCE HAD TO WRITE ABOUT THESE
THINGS AND BRING THEM TO THE
FOREIGN THERE WAS A GREAT AMOUNT
OF INTERNET SPECULATION AS WELL
THERE'S LOTS OF ISSUES AND A LOT
OF THINGS THAT JAY Z CAN TAKE TO
TASK IN ONE OF THEM IS THE
PUSHING FOR.
THEY HAVE THE HARDEST TIME
ENTERING THE WORKFORCE.
THAT'S A REAL ISSUE.
SAYING MONEY DOESN'T BUY
MISERABLE BUT FOR THOSE WITH
ZERO MOBILITY AND NO CHOICES AND
NO CHANCE TO MOVE UP, A LITTLE
BIT OF MONEY AND A NICE JOB SURE
WOULD BE REFRESHING CONSIDERING
HOW THE CARDS HAVE BEEN STACKED
AGAINST MANY PEOPLE THAT JAY Z
IS SUPPOSEDLY DEFENDING.
FOUND THE S-HOLE COMMENTS TO BE
HURTFUL.
HAS JAY Z EVER LISTENED TO HIS
OWN LYRICS ABOUT WOMEN?
>> Juan: I'M NOT A FAN OF
THOSE THINGS.
I THINK IN THIS MISOGYNISTIC AND
PERCENTAGES, IT'S OVERWHELMINGLY
WHO THE FANS ARE.
>> Kimberly: SAYING A LARGER
NUMBER --
THIS >> Juan: YOU ASKED ABOUT
BIGGER.
BUT I WORRY ABOUT IT IN TERMS OF
THE BLACK AUDIENCE.
WON, SO I DON'T UNDERSTAND THAT.
WHEN IT COMES TO SOMETHING LIKE
FROM THAT.
THAT'S WHAT THE MAN SAID.
>> Greg: ALL RIGHT, JESSE.
>> Jesse: I LOVE JAY Z.
SUPER BOWL TICKETS.
>> Greg: HE DOESN'T DEAL
ANYMORE, SO YOU DON'T NEED
ANYTHING.
YOUR FEELINGS ARE HURT AND YOU
ARE A RAPPER.
COME ON.
AND THEN YOU'RE SAYING BLACK
UNEMPLOYMENT, RECORD LOW AND HE
IS SAYING IT'S NOT ABOUT MONEY.
EVERY SONG HE SINGS IS ABOUT
GETTING MORE MONEY.
TRUMP'S TONE IS POLITE QUEENS
ENGLISH COMPARED TO SOME OF HIS
THEY LOVE ATTENTION.
THEY BOTH HAVE BIG MOUTHS.
>> Greg: THEY ARE EQUALS.
THEY ARE.
IT'S A DIFFERENT GENERATION.
>> Kennedy: WOULDN'T YOU LIKE
TO HEAR A CONVERSATION BETWEEN
THE TWO OF THEM.
>> Greg: I THINK THEY WOULD
PLAY GOLF.
LOVE TO HANG OUT WITH HIM.
>> Kimberly: IT IS
HYPOCRITICAL.
JAY Z OBVIOUSLY HAS A VOICE.
HE'S VERY TALENTED.
HE COULD USE IT IN A MORE
EFFECTIVE, POWERFUL WAY TO HELP
IN THE BLACK COMMUNITY AND AS IT
RELATES TO JOBS AND WHATNOT.
PRESIDENT SAID HE WAS GOING TO
TRY TO DO IT AND EARN THE BONES
AND IMPROVE THE ON EMPLOYMENT
NUMBERS AND HE'S DONE THAT.